[Music]
Americans love beer on average 42
percent of them prefer it to any other
kind of alcohol so you might not be
shocked to hear that according to
multiple studies over half of American
adults have a beer gut
but don't swear off your Friday night
called one just yet because it's not
beer specifically that's to blame Apple
or our glass oval or inverted triangle
everyone has their own body shape and
that's partially because people store
fat in different places depending on
their genetics and hormones for women
popular spots include the thighs arms
and backside while men tend to store fat
in their bellies much of it is a type of
fat called visceral fat which lurks deep
within the stomach in men visceral fat
tends to pile up behind the abdominal
wall where it pushes the ABS outward
creating a protruding beer belly though
that name beer belly is kind of a
misnomer because beer bellies aren't
exclusive to beer drinkers that's
because the problem isn't the actual
beer its the calories inside it on
average your favorite ale contains
around 150 calories per can that's 30 to
50 more calories than a 5 ounce glass of
wine and 45 more than a shot of whiskey
and if you don't burn them off those
extra calories can go straight to your
gut but not only do the number of
calories matter but the kind of calories
beer contains high levels of processed
carbs which research shows can interfere
with insulin levels and promote fat
storage around your organs and while a
serving of wine for instance contains
just one or two grams of carbs a serving
of beer contains 10 to 20 it doesn't
really matter whether these calories and
carbs come from beer specifically or
from some other kind of junk food so the
good news is beer and moderation
shouldn't give you a beer belly that
being said no matter where it comes from
a beer belly is bad
News that's because visceral fat wraps
around your kidneys liver and intestines
and releases hormones that can disrupt
their normal function and that can lead
to issues like type 2 diabetes heart
disease and even cancer if that's not
bad enough
once your belly runs out of room to
store that visceral fat your body might
start building it up inside nearby
organs which can lead to fatty liver
disease and other issues in fact one
study found that men with beer bellies
or a waist-to-hip ratio over 0.9 had a
87% higher risk for death than those who
carried the same amount of fat in other
parts of their bodies 87 percent that's
right so even if you're otherwise skinny
a spare tire can threaten your life and
guys are more likely to grow a gut as
they get older because testosterone a
sex hormone that helps keep men slim
decreases with age so while it's fun to
joke about you're developing dadbod
maybe just stick to having one or two
brewskis a night instead of the whole
six-pack